let's do it let's just [ __ ] do it
let's do this [ __ ] huh yay hello ladies
and gentlemen what's up this is date
fails I'm Kate Quigley I'm here all
things comedy I am pumped because I got
two studs in the house today
hotties this is what I do I just invite
hot guys to do my podcast basically I
feel like The Bachelorette today like
what if I secretly invited you guys here
to decide which one of you gets the rose
[ __ ] fight over it Brian go Roy are you
you'd be like Adam you don't care about
your past what are you talking about
what are you [ __ ] on water beds and
motels that [ __ ] cost for hourly
one-time listen one time this is a true
story I had a guy come to meet me at the
improv for a drink and then we wanted to
hook up and I couldn't take him back to
my apartment because at the time I had
Eric Myers sleeping in my kitchen oh my
yeah so I didn't want to [ __ ] with Eric
and when we go back to why the [ __ ] is
Eric speaking there's other places like
a coucher right well I let Eric live
with me for I think it was like three or
four months and but I told him that he
couldn't live in my living room because
I don't like to like I don't like to
have someone in my living room all the
time I want to use it but I have a
dining room like at attention and Eric
I'm making a yes I emptied out the like
in area of the kitchen and Eric put a
futon in it and a desk and a little like
divider and you lived in my kitchen
that's so fun it's like it was a kitchen
it well I have an eat-in kitchen and I
don't use it like I seriously keep like
blankets in the oven all right yeah [ __ ]
do you cook I cook a lot all the time
well I don't cook I don't collect it in
the oven I love it is orders gonna
blanket going so anyway I couldn't take
the guy back to my place so we were like
well let's just get a cheap motel room
and hook up and so there's a motel in my
neighborhood and it says like water beds
pay-by-the-hour you know local calls
free cable television it's one of those
like shitty motel
and I just thought it would be a funny
story like let's do it there yeah but it
turns out sex on a waterbed is difficult
and I do the same thing for the story I
did heroine for eight years on school I
thought it'd be fun yeah come on and
that's how do they believed you have you
really no fun Oh have you ever tried
heroin I've done it accidentally
probably what do you mean like you know
on pills and maybe snorted some [ __ ] and
put it in a pill ya know like in like
ecstasy or some [ __ ] like it's you know
you don't know what they [ __ ] put in
writing these pills I've always wanted
to try heroin really it won't let just
ones I won't do it because I'm afraid
also but I just feel like it it's so
good it ruins lives so it has to be like
yeah I don't think I yeah I don't think
I would do it knowingly yeah not one
thing I haven't like one drug I haven't
[ __ ] with it I don't think a heroin is
in right now my home town I grew up in
your kids are like OD yeah stand right
on it [ __ ] are you sorry because they're
getting hooked on like the oxycottons
and like the the painkiller shits and
then they go when they can't afford
cause I guess those things are so
expensive too if you don't have right
insurance plan or whatever the [ __ ] I
don't know but house kids here we don't
have insurance to pay for your drug
habit well no you know time I like that
like they like hurt their back
snowboarding or some [ __ ] oh yeah he's
like painkillers and then they switch to
heroin and then they don't know how to
use heroin they overdose heroin is
cheaper than oxygen I think so I think
like in some shitty heroin I don't know
shitty right not the premium quality I
have no clue you I don't know how the
heroines not my rights ain't never done
it I've never done it either I've never
done math either have you guys tried
Madison you have yep how is that I want
to on us I I mean not regularly but like
I've done it in like a [ __ ] in a
pinch like I did it in Mexico one time
out of a light bulb well like we were us
like [ __ ] seventeen weeks to go party
in Mexico they grew up in Orange County
and on like we go to this hotel room it
was called the hotel california and it's
in my great pasty jane Rosarita and
we're partying there and then like we
hear these guys just [ __ ] so loud in
the room next to us and at that time we
just party with everyone right and there
were these [ __ ] Mexican dudes like
doing meth and they're like oh and we're
not going to learn it at club we're
cleaning over here is club for clay any
club
they're calling their room club 420 they
were like this hot box in the whole
place let's go smoke some weed and we
went in there we start smoking weed and
the guy say it dry didn't one and it was
a [ __ ] it was like you know you put
the meth in the in the lightbulb and cut
them like put a hole in the I guess si
you can do it she put like a jeffrey
basin chi pipe i guess i didn't know
that and I smoke like that and I did it
a handful other times I think wow what
was it like did yeah you did your heart
just like good it no I man we were
partying so it's just like doing coke
times a billion that was I wonder what
it's like and and and people cut yolk or
you get shitty coke sometimes and it's
got meth in it right you know I think I
might have had that but I don't know I'd
probably done meth okay by accident I
did a gig one time this is actually so
funny and I I did a gig and it was in
this like [ __ ] town and I drove out
there it's like a four-hour drive from
here I don't to say where is that I
don't know put these people I'm glad no
I can't sake there's really like one no
value in the town right so I Drive out
there and I had the longest day I think
I'd like shot my show all day and then
made this Drive and I was so tired and I
know they do a lot of coke out there
like the guy that owns this place in
this front so I was like hey man I'm so
exhausted do you think like do I got a
bump guys get a bump I just need to wake
up and he was like man he's like you
know what the town is really dry on coke
right now but we've got lots of math Joe
Billy's cooking it up right now yeah and
I was like doing came in the [ __ ]
bathroom I said you know you're in a
shitty town like we're shitty bet when
they're like all we have here's matter
you know I've been in those situations
like after shows and [ __ ] and you're
[ __ ] you know Harry dark hanging out
and talk to John sense make such a
camping plans with some random I'm such
a purely nice boy I'm not ready to get
that [ __ ] out of here but I feel like
I'm still but you're not you are talking
about when I was a kid I was a [ __ ]
angel nice I still feel like I'm a I'm
an angel but I've done coke and I likes
to [ __ ] yeah I like to [ __ ] well I mean
I don't do it I don't do anything much
but occasional I drink I mean I drink
obviously you can't have like you know
I mean you know you see I know people
that have big problems in [ __ ] yeah I
don't want to be like one of those guys
I mean I really have a career if you get
your products what I was saying I mean
some guys and then you see that it's
[ __ ] up a lot of guys that were on
like their trajectory 100 I don't want
to say any names but you know their
trajectory was there and then all of a
sudden the drugs cut I definitely know
guys that are so talented that should be
so much more famous than they are and
you know it's just like the partying is
the thing that's holding them but on
that note I should introduce you guys
instead of just freaking to do the whole
podcast I never say the two guys that
did cocaine to guy the guy that did meth
out of a light bulb hell yeah look for
training you guys are both amazing I
love you both
first of all I have comedian actor
youtuber former do you say former vine
star now because I feel like this oh
yeah guest vine is is done but I feel
like you're gonna have something else
like any time now you're gonna have like
a your own your own series on MTV or
some crazy God just wish to show didn't
OSHA MTV picked this [ __ ] up
ah it's ride doing everybody right
problem it likes to [ __ ] I like the
first and and Amir you're like seriously
one of my favorite comments like I mean
no matter how many times I see you I
like laugh every that's that's all I
know a comedian is amazing by the way
because I'll watch you like over and
over and keep laughing thank you he's
hilarious let's see you've been on a
million things as a church with cameras
on MTV MADtv
ladies and gentlemen I'll be okay what's
up with MADtv are you guys do you know I
don't know officially if they said
anything so I don't I don't I don't see
anybody but I mean it's like you know
yeah I don't know you don't know about
it that's fine yet but it's a fun show
and I just want to do yeah a lot of fun
I mean I wish it wasn't like maybe you
know if we had some more freedom like to
do more of the [ __ ] we wanted to do
would have been probably a little bit
more loose sure because but it was on
prime time you know CW looks like I can
only do yeah you can only do so much
can't do meth out of a lipo
yeah I crazy the edgy [ __ ] you know
Shane uh you definitely get well listen
and I'm very excited to have both you
here and before we get into this I have
a sponsor on today's show listen you
guys here we go I have to say you guys
both have amazing skin by the way I feel
like yeah I do yeah you don't have look
at you no blemishes really I feel like I
have like frail Irish skin I'm going to
look old like any minute but no you have
a total baby face and like very like
pink your complexion right thank you
compliment you look like a newborn now
yeah like a very pretty [ __ ] no I'm
just kidding you gotta see this
I think no you have great skin you have
to have great skin in our business you
can't show up looking like a hot mess
Ahmir you know despite this dark circles
I think that's the only if they ever put
makeup on me it's like the lady spends
an hour and a half covering up my [ __ ]
middle eternally I I guess the dark
circles too I think that's from caffeine
that's what they say or do you drink a
lot of caffeine I don't I don't know
what it is maybe I don't get enough
sleep or some [ __ ] you know it could be
just because you wear a lot of black it
brings out yeah I don't see any circles
you look really yeah yeah well guys I
care a lot about my skin I really I
really do I loofah my butt cheeks every
day and I care about my face skin as
well which is why I recently started
using bio clarity this is true they sent
me a sample and I have to say usually
when I get samples I try it and I think
the stuff is crap but this stuff is
actually it's amazing I don't want to
brag but I think I'm a little glowy I
feel like I'm a little what would you
say I'm blowing or than usual you look
pregnant you're a woman but uh but
that's my rental Motel right haha I get
a hotel I just I just I die I'm
flattered that you would get a hotel
room with me despite the fact you know
that I had sex on a waterbed once now
I'm saying
but guys listen life is better when
you're confident in your skin and bio
clarity is the way to do it it will help
reveal the real use you can take on
school work social media maybe you can
even post a photo without a filter if
you start using awesome I know that
would be amazing shots fired
ah shot very good bio clarity has
naturally calming and cleansing extracts
including green tea and chamomile it
cools and soo
your skin it really does cool your skin
I love that feeling also you can use
this to treat acne however it's all
natural it does not use benzoyl peroxide
which causes redness dryness and
irritation clinical studies have shown
strong results including a significant
significant reduction in the number of
blemishes improved overall appearance of
facial skin reduced oiliness and
shininess that's big for me I get very
shiny so less shining out without drying
on your drying out your skin so guys
here's the thing it's 100% vegan its
cruelty free gluten free which I am and
paraben free so I want you guys to
definitely get it this is what I'm
telling you go to bio clarity calm my
listeners get their first month for only
nine ninety five plus free shipping
which saves you $20 and it's a hundred
percent risk-free money-back guarantee
so you guys can try it out if you don't
like it you can send it back you just
have to enter my code date that's right
go to bio clarity comm and enter my code
date and try it out bio clarity calm I'm
going to get you guys some by the way so
definitely does not end it to me I want
that cooling feeling and also it's
something I eat it with [ __ ]
guacamole gluten free no paraben huh
shove it up your ass I don't know if
it's edible but you can use it on your
ass I I do use it on my ass as well
that's not condoned but you can you can
try it so so that's that guys check it
out bio clarity calm and thank you guys
for sponsoring the show it's so nice to
have a sponsor yeah it's a good feeling
to get beyond your legit now that
because there you have a good skin you
know anyway so back to life um you back
to Rhiannon what's the what's uh what's
going on with you yeah you guys are both
single right single yeah yeah yeah I
have like low key crushes on both you
guys brilliant yeah well you guys are
both really cute you know and you both
seem disease-free see I don't have I
don't have evidence of this uh Ryan are
you going to tell me this story so when
I hit up Ryan and said come do the
podcast with me and a mirror he was like
I actually have a great story involving
girls yeah it's probably gonna be a
short story it's cooler for a mirror he
fared
is it though I'm [ __ ] up I don't know
yeah we talked about because we don't
really hang out often and we never
really hung out until this night really
it was at The Improv yeah that's our
first time here's my backstory I was at
the improv I did a show in the lab
afterwards a girl came to the show I had
never met her
we're talking we're trying to talk but
and there's some dude lingering
lingering Vermeer's I was a [ __ ] Emir
and then I was like it after two hours
like do you know him she's like now look
what the [ __ ]
so we got rid of him but then she had to
go we're hitting it off we make out
outside it gets me all horny wait you
just met her that night and you guys are
already making out she had known I
apparently I used to make fine videos in
the Starbucks she used to work in so she
knew me that is hilarious I haven't seen
you just from she's just watching from
afar why do I get to make out one crotch
I know at a time yeah I was just like
I'm so impressed with these girls that
like meet a guy and then are making out
with them like and now I mean even if
she know you're [ __ ] in Motel yeah
yeah I just couldn't do it I couldn't go
to go to his [ __ ] house what no he
lived far away so we had to do it in a
motel and it was a guy hooked up as
before like doctors and rest time and
you never do that then on there like if
you ever know you meet somebody and
you're like oh hey I just guys kind of
cool any ticket and then your idea have
fun and [ __ ] happens only one time I
ever had sex with a guy I met on the
road and it wasn't a random it was like
a guy it was a football player that I
was like trying to hook up with oh
that's it was that me honestly so in the
top five bad ice axes sexes it's always
better when it's like a professional
football player
yeah yeah I always say that I mean if
I'm gonna here's my big I don't hook up
with randoms lot but I'm a chick right
it's different it's different because
the odds of a guy being great in bed I
feel are like one in six so if I'm going
to [ __ ] someone it needs to be someone
that I've researched heavily and I feel
like the chances are really good they're
gonna be waiting some good dick really
good okay yeah but back to you and your
makeout yes this girl's lovely or we're
now dating
[Music]
we're seeing each other whatever anyways
the backstory is I was hanging out that
girl at the improv then she had to go
home and I look back but I was all like
I don't know it sounds creepy but I was
horny well yeah yeah doesn't sound
creepy you guys made out and they leave
yep and then I was like ah dammit and
then all of a sudden a girl I have never
seen me forces like hey come over my
place and I was like okay and then
that's when I see a mirror president I
would anything happened yeah and then I
was over there and then and there's an a
I don't want to get other people
involved in the story but there was one
of our friends we were till friend okay
and then we were just like what the [ __ ]
what are we doing like and then it was
we ended up partying and having a good
time and then all of a sudden I left is
three dudes two girls one of the girls
was attractive does the girl you were
mingling with yes she was really
attractive and then I was like honestly
I was like maybe cuz I know you didn't
know her anything I was like maybe a
mirror will leave and then I'll do in
the waiting game uh idea I was like
alright we were just like shooting the
[ __ ] and I know he was [ __ ] sitting
there writing so you're like a beer get
the [ __ ] out of here I was open to you
leaving but hey whatever what about the
not so hot girl no way when I went
outside for a smoke you locked the door
yeah he said he was going home anyways
guys [ __ ] cigarette wait so there's
two girls and only one is hot what's
going on with the other chick what is
anyone talking to her yeah yeah we're
all we're all just hanging out in the
kitchen you know that talkin [ __ ]
everyone's nice everyone's laughing got
it wasn't nothing like creepy or devious
really yeah except for in my head is
like if a merely Oh leave it and we
didn't know each other like okay like we
don't you know hang all right I was like
I don't know like very little waiting
game so then what happened
ah then Amir did not leave unfortunately
uh-huh I mean I left at some point but I
took the girl with me right nice work
and uh I'll just made out with the other
girl
are you dead yeah I see that's the
difference between guys and girls like
guys are like I'll just settle for the
next best thing like I don't think a
chick would ever do that I feel like a
lot of guys would do that some guys
don't though yes I mean
yeah well you what were you sober no I
was pretty drunk yeah honestly I think
it's okay then I mean girls play the
waiting game I played the waiting game
recently oh I had a thing did I tell
this on your errand did I tell the story
on here about how I went to a guide
birthday party and then he ended up
making out with me and then a different
chick later yeah I told that story oh
that sucks no the bad night I told her
yeah well I mean but here's the thing
like that night I thought about doing
the waiting like I've been in situations
where I'm like who's going to get this
guy we're all waiting and you can tell I
think people that took common theme from
guys and girls huh I feel like one yeah
two groups meet and they're hanging out
I used to go vibing basic cotton i
seconded eight this superhot girl and
she would flirt with every dude in the
world like he first better night
together she just go off and forever
somebody but she was so hot and I'm so
insecure that I just play the waiting
game
haha Oh like maybe she'll come home with
me Oh what you guys weren't dating this
trick not really but I liked her I am
feelings for her I got the feels that
happens sometimes like well that's
that's interesting you brought that up
because okay so have you ever had a
friend that you have like a lot of
sexual attention with for a long time
and you kind of flirt but you never hook
up yeah dude yeah um yeah I mean besides
us obviously oh yeah I think so but then
that [ __ ] sometimes
then you do hook up and it ruins the
relationship like it will [ __ ] up the
friendship it can well like I have two
scenarios right now like there's one guy
okay I have this guy friend he's super
hot
when we first met we kind of were like
flirting and then we kind of we sort of
dated like we went on a couple dates we
made out but we didn't [ __ ] right he
comedian um maybe yeah maybe but we
didn't hook up but then like this is
crazy after like three times hanging out
and we didn't hook up he just kind of
stopped like trying so I he's a comics
in it for me I don't like to [ __ ] with
ya like FEMA comment yeah other comics I
just don't because it's just too much
we're in the same [ __ ] you know and it's
like I don't want to have like a
weird thing when I'm at a club and she's
at a club or something is if something
weird happened but so that could be a
thing with this guy I totally agree and
and I but and by the way this was like a
few years ago and I've always had the
same thing with comics but it's funny
because this guy and I then we didn't we
quit hanging out in that capacity the
hilarious thing is when a guy like when
I get that close to hooking up with a
guy and then he kind of ghosts me that
makes me want to [ __ ] like million
times more yes so then I started like
trying to bait him into just sex you
know what I mean like I was like how is
this guy not going to [ __ ] me then I
started sending in my naked photos and
like I'd be like in his neighborhood and
be like him in your neighborhood was up
there and he kept on your goddamn sexual
pressure I like a guy I'm like a guy I
am and exactly I got a [ __ ] Jesus
Christ
well no it's just the thing is I'm a I'm
like a guy in the sense that if I get
close so get like I wasn't planning to
hook up with him at all I liked him but
then once he lost interest it's just
human nature you won't we can't have
type [ __ ] yeah and also I knew we'd have
good sex because we had good chemistry I
was just trying to do the whole waiting
thing and then it blew up in my face I
waited too long and he was like it's too
much work wait I'm not telling us an
idea I know mommy's I can't tell I know
I'm though well we're still friends so
you definitely know him I'll tell you
later but anyway so we then I'll tell it
on my podcast guy yeah so we didn't hook
up but but the reason I'm bringing it up
is because then like maybe six months
ago one night we were partying so this
whole thing started like three years ago
like six months ago one night we were
really partying and we ended up going
back to his place and we almost hooked
up definitely got like naked fooled
around but we didn't [ __ ] the color all
you guys have well cuz because we
partied so much that he couldn't oh yeah
yeah I started one of what think I know
this is no no so I'm nervous but I was
glad that we didn't the next day because
I was like oh because we're friends and
maybe it would have made [ __ ] weird who
knows
odhh and you know when you kind of fool
around and you're that [ __ ] up how you
almost feel like it didn't happen like
have you ever done that where you wake
up the next day and it almost feels like
a dream I've I've just completely not
remembered having sex the only time I
roofied you but your dick is hard I
don't feel that bad oh very I don't know
but anyway the point is we didn't hook
up that night and whenever we see each
other we kind of always joke like oh one
of these days whatever but we never have
but last night at a sex dream about this
guy what is it
if not this guy who I've never had a sex
dream about him before and here's the
thing in the dream the sex was amazing
so then I woke up I mean yes such a high
standard for this thing if it does
happen spine necklace right that's the
point that's what I were thinking now
it's going to be it can't possibly be as
good so that was what I was wondering
have you guys ever had someone that you
had this much tension with for a long
time and then finally fogged I've
definitely had like girls maybe that
like in the past that I was like really
you know into and stuff and then once it
happened I wasn't is as good as you taya
maybe they thought the same [ __ ] maybe
that's what I think would happen yeah I
think when you build it up so much it's
inevitable you know it can't be as good
yeah and then also I guess yeah you know
never do it is if you're right when is
this much time building up yeah dude
come on yeah I don't have a particular
story where I was disappointed or like
built it up two months but I did hook up
with the comedian wants people was it me
I love even a female comedian like I
assume I'm straight yeah and and it made
things weird who was it do we both know
her yeah for sure
oh really it like we were hanging out
like a legit comic uh like a working
comic because that narrows it down to
like tell everybody no she is eat yeah
okay but we like each other and I even
vocalizes though sometimes I talk too
much I'll say what's on my mind I said
like so I like you you like me
right before I went direct we knew we
both wanted to bang and I was just I
just brought it up like let's just we
like each other let's go do this pretty
much she was like I wish you didn't say
that
wait you just brought it up like
casually like you were at a comedy club
and you were like we should [ __ ] no we
were hanging out all night and like
drinking and stuff we're back in my
apartment it was like 6 a.m. is one of
those nights I'm like it's time to wrap
this up but uh I just would wrap this up
no pun well I did not and that's what
made it weird she's pregnant now oh sure
congratulations
I'm skinny iCarly right doing jr. yeah
but uh long story short it wasn't that
good because I think we both like each
other for like two two years Wow and now
it's a little bit awkward really that's
crazy I can't believe you say Wanda
Sykes ha ha I'm jealous I would [ __ ]
Wanda Sykes honestly I just I'm a really
big fan that's it one comic yeah I'm
pretty good with not hooking up with
friends or people I work with I am to
for the most part I mean that one dude I
almost don't even count him at this
point because it's just become like a
running it's almost like a running joke
now like oh just like Oh Brian Redman I
can't believe oh yeah I know I know
no Brian and I haven't hooked up but
it's hilarious Chris Brian says that we
like went on a bunch of dates and I deny
that we ever went on dates because
apparently to Brian they were dates to
me we're just hanging out oh really yeah
yeah we talked about it on here because
he's like we definitely went on dates
I'm like how is it if we don't kiss to
me it's not a date
well I mean the answer what's the
intention of the [ __ ] you know it was
like hey look I'm gonna take you to
dinner or some [ __ ]
well he did oh I mean I thought it was
acid value like if I said a mirror yeah
I I think you're awesome let's grab
dinner like you and I are already
friends so we went and got dinner and I
mean I guess it's the context I don't
know unless you make out a it's the way
that you asked or the way that you go
about it I mean there should be a clear
thing but I think good I think women
have that line blurred more than dudes
like if I ask a chick out
I know it's gonna be you know that's a
date a date I guess I don't know unless
I ask her like hey dude let's just go
grab
thank you [ __ ] though you call her
dude is it a date yeah that can be
frustrating though I saw a girl that I
recognized from a dating app and because
she bikini is really educating it run
reason why I recognize her because she's
a comedian in a profiles look oh yeah I
know her so like researchers look like
do I never she worked at flappers and I
didn't know her that's why I recognized
her then I saw her at the Comedy Store
that's okay
grumble she's like okay please wouldn't
ya good line she ran away like hiding
like what I don't want to be friends but
I'm not to be like hey we mentioned
dating yet but I just want to be friends
like it but she thought I was hitting on
her she gave me a fake number she she
did not I didn't ask for her number
she's like yeah we should like that
talking crazy she goes here's a fit
maybe she didn't mean to give you a fake
number and was you pepper that's weird
why would she give you a fake number
when you're both commitment if you
didn't ask for her number right
like that's [ __ ] up yeah what did you
not say gave it to you and then for the
rest of the night she wouldn't we like
make eye contact briefly then she'd look
down or away not smile I'm like well
didn't help every time she look at you I
mean I'm on all the dating apps I did
the creepy thing the other day of like I
went on I'm on this app happen are you
on this app you want any dating app
Samia I mean I [ __ ] around with like
like looked at tinder and like bumble
and she liked that but I haven't I've
never gone on a date from one you don't
well this app happened I'm kind of
obsessed with it this I think is the
best one because so say you're at a club
or a bar and you're drinking and you're
buzzed and you're like I kind of want to
meet a hot guy or girl to like hang with
this app tells you literally like who's
the closest in proximity to you like by
feet almost like one night it was like
you've matched with someone who's eight
hundred yards away what a measure
alcohol no but I went on there drinking
qi0
I know so I went on there and I I'm a
this guy like two years ago but he was
like the hottest guy in my list and we
had 14 mutual friends I actually did the
creepy stalker thing of like going
on Facebook finding him then I messaged
a few friends and was like what's up
with this guy you know like is he cool
and then a few people were like he is
cool so I added him on Facebook a
message if I'm such a dude I'm a total
data guy I really oh hey dude cool oh
man yeah but then you know what he did I
think it's so hot he wrote me back and
said we matched on that app two years
ago I think I owe you a drink by now and
I was like I think you do and he goes
nine o'clock tonight yeah guys never do
that anymore
like when you guys ask girls out two
weeks from now yeah or like hey do you
know I don't know or they never Adam
I've heard on the dating apps they've
never asked a girl out or they just do
this thing of like there's this la thing
guys do that I hate which is like they
don't make a plan they go like oh yeah
we should grab a drink sometime let's
play it by ear hit me up when you're
done with your spot everything is play
by ear right do you guys play everything
by ear
I don't think about apps like that but
what about like when you meet someone if
I meet somebody and I'm going to take
them out I think I have a plan I'm like
where we're gonna go what we're gonna do
after you know I usually make a plan one
reason because I know girls don't like
the whole play by ear and two it's just
I don't know I like to plan yeah I mean
it's just like so hot to me when guys
plan [ __ ] out yes I know have you guys
uh you guys dealt with any crazy chicks
out here I feel like there's a lot of
crazy girls in LA had any crazy girls oh
yeah I guess it's few but I mean yeah I
don't want to I don't want to sit
because we all know the same people you
know oh you you're talking
it's girls we know I think so yeah I
know I met one girl at the comic store
one night not a comedian this is when I
was going through like a [ __ ] days I was
always protected but I was like haha
yeah because you came on here before
when I was doing this podcast with
Stephen Kramer Gluckman and you were in
a relationship I think so you were you
were like very like virginal at the time
I was with in it with a girlfriend for
10 years yeah that's right we have the
same like story yeah
no matter you get horny yeah yeah no
wonder you're going through a [ __ ] phase
like
I went through a slot phase right after
my 10-year marriage I was married
I'm out of my slow phase I'm almost
concerned I'm Kim I like a sex drive but
there's one night I call me story I
brought a girl home uh we banked the
note the next morning I get up to use
the bathroom I step in a puddle on my
carpet like I must have spilled water
then I go back to bed and we're lying in
bed she's awake I'm awake all of a
sudden sicko
oh my god did I pee somewhere no next Oh
Peter my carpet are you serious yeah
holy [ __ ] I did I pee so much I wonder
how often she does that high all the
time baby I'll tell ya all the time
she'll do it again I didn't have her
over again but she's like oh my god that
happens to me all the time do you - no I
random check of the store not very
random she's friends with some comedians
but uh she's cool yeah the circle so so
I hate ruining cuz we're at the
nightclub so much the same comedy club
so much that I don't like ruining those
you know what I mean then I see a when
it gets yeah that makes sense
I don't like [ __ ] around like that so
like not a same she a like wait random
she just knows one comedian waitress has
never I've never hooked up with one I
don't hook up with anyone who works at
comedy clubs and I haven't I just don't
do it anymore I mean I try not to do it
anymore
next it makes it weird it does make it
weird and I only talk to orange stars
now that is er I'm kidding no I'm
kidding I'm done with porn stars I think
I bug guy porn stars uh yes no way I am
well I dated one for a while that I
talked about on here a ton I'm not
allowed to talk about anymore oh you
can't say I'm not allowed to talk about
him anymore because I talked about him
on here and it turned out he had a
girlfriend that I didn't know about who
listens to the show and Wow
so he was very unhappy that I outed him
cheating on her basically
so now no less but I have hooked up with
I have hooked up with a couple porn
actors but here's an amazing ridiculous
so good it's crazy I mean like honestly
hooking up with porn actors I would
suggest never doing it if you're a girl
because it kind of ruins you for regular
is it really yeah because they're
professionals you know
their whole job is to be like an expert
of your post like it's crazy so and they
have been no inhibitions because they're
like you know they're always like acting
out scenes and [ __ ] so no so they just
start acting out scenes with like with
you it's really bad I mean I was
addicted I was kind of low-key I never
said it on here but I think I was
honestly like a little addicted to
[ __ ] porn guys at one point because I
hoped up with two and then I kind of had
never told this on here I kind of dove
with a third but I didn't know like I
didn't he was important well yeah until
he entered yeah so I I was like wow what
are the odds that this is what he does
well I don't watch a lot of porn but
after the AVN Awards it was like dope
yeah you did a anymore yeah so I had I
had this streak where it was like I
wasn't [ __ ] anyone and when I would
get really hard up I'd be like well why
not call in a professional so I went
this is so embarrassing to admit but I
are blushing though it's good to see you
honorable I know because it's like it's
so embarrassing but I'm not going to lie
like they're so good and there's they're
clean right they have to be like you
know right well yeah they get tested
like all the time so in my mind I'm just
like this is you know it's almost like
masturbating but with like a person it's
like that safe have you ever tried a
flashlight I'm here I have not tried a
flashlight you want one I have the
standard of training yet at home thank
you do you really want to try one no I
got never tried one and like I've done
like the Noddy shows and I hear handing
them out like no you don't have I'm
gonna go on I did a show and I got paid
with it
you can use a flashlight the naughty
show I want to carefully name shown oh
yeah as always a naughty show that I
cater dude and I'm like I didn't I just
never I would always leave to another
set or some [ __ ] I was like oh okay oh
yeah you got to try it and let me know
how it is under breath I always wonder
how you wash them though do you put it
in the dishwasher you know what tripoli
gave me a travel sized flashlight with
josh has an opening on the end so like
your dick goes out of the end
all right so you don't like actually
into it yeah uh-huh
you can choose out it's like a pocket
vagina so we travel it uh yes great so I
still had to clean it but it wasn't like
filled with jizz
that's what various are you guys into
like you guys use any like toys or
anything when you were chicks mmm I mean
girlfriends probably yep not not like
not like hey hey their first night
gigging here's a [ __ ] dildo I don't
know I went to home with a guy one time
and when we were out the gate he's like
here we're doing this and he's got the
[ __ ] well yeah well I walked in his
room and he had like just a bunch of
[ __ ] like hanging on his wall I get like
a paddle I'm like a whip at all didn't
that cause for concern there I'm raising
undo it I was like here's the thing I
think every girl is like low-key kind of
like curious about that stuff right
you know like versus 50 she's yeah
honestly yeah I love that I love it but
it's got to be a guy that like knows
what he's doing
I've noticed choking is in choking is
very good I've noticed killing murdering
people and afterwards [ __ ] the dead
body is hot haha
it is this is true choking is you trying
I love choking little it can be scary as
a dude was like how hard do I choke
really well I mean if she turned to blue
you let go I mean I think that like all
girls kind of want a guy to beat them up
in bed yeah I punch girls in the face do
you all the time good boy I know there's
no elbows I call ground-and-pound man
yeah I don't know I always get like
weird about that [ __ ] you know cuz I'm
like [ __ ] and then it gets too much and
you know I don't know and then it gets
tiring
I'm tired of men is having you do it
everywhere I'm and it's like every I'm
am i choking you now like I have to do
this every [ __ ] time you don't have
to do it the whole time though I know I
might have done it it's like moments I
don't know like I'll have really streaky
with the sex game you know I could be
really good or just [ __ ] [ __ ] you
know what I doubt you're ever dogs you
know I'm serious like I don't know it's
like sometimes just not like heavy into
the [ __ ] you know then sometimes you're
like oh all in what do you think makes
you
dog [ __ ] and bad as a guy cocaine Oh
drinking oh yeah that could [ __ ] you up
and I've had such bad showings sometimes
you know y'all you know sluggish messes
girl god damn it and then you like this
is what I'm doing
oh that's the word and it's just like
what the [ __ ] is this and then I got God
guys never [ __ ] a girl that you were
intimidated and so you couldn't stay
hard
I like nervous does that happen I asking
for yourself you know I would have to do
a lot
no I asking I'm just curious because
like I hooked up with a guy one time
that that was what he said but then in
my head I wondered if that was just like
an excuse and he just can't ever get it
up
no I I've definitely had it where that's
happened but I think as I've gotten
older when I was younger dude it was
like I would have a bone or 24 hours a
day now it's like [ __ ] it I got to
really be into the [ __ ] for me to like
go you know really I mean not really
into it but I mean you know if I've been
drinking and done blower she could [ __ ]
me up yeah and there are some nights I'm
sure you've experiences Ahmir where
everything's working great and Mikey you
are king oh dude I have that too I do
have that do wear a crown it's true I
don't know what it is exactly maybe it's
the alcohol or some [ __ ] but as I gotten
older like you know there are some
nights where I'm like what the [ __ ] is
going on yeah I think it's a chemistry
thing that too and if I'm really into a
chick though it's like on you know it's
like [ __ ] I'm good but if I'm not
it's like you know one of those like on
the fence and I'm just doing it because
it's there oh yeah not you know it's not
going to be that's the thing well I've
been reading a lot of like self-help
stuff because when I went through my
porn stuff this is real when I went
through the porn star phase I had a
moment of like okay Kate like what the
[ __ ] is wrong with you like something
there's clearly some damage here because
like it's not normal to be like wanting
to hook up with a bunch of porn you know
what I think that 10 years of marriage
[ __ ] really [ __ ] stun into your
sexual what did
yeah so that's why you're getting it out
now I mean that makes complete sense to
me yeah but the thing is that it would
make sense if I was getting it out like
[ __ ] law to people but I don't like I
would hook up
I would just have this little rotation
of the same people like my numbers still
low but I only [ __ ] like awful I'm not
saying the porn guys are awful cuz I'm
friends with some of them but I'm saying
like I would only [ __ ] like terrible
terrible people like I want to [ __ ] guys
with like teardrop tattoos who like
might like choke me to death
was your ex-boyfriend uh sweetheart the
guy's name that X has a super sweet may
be really your law school in the ed
against the type you know yeah but now
I've been listening to like these like
self-help podcasts and stuff about like
about like addictive sexual behavior
and what I learned is they say when
you're really into someone like if you
meet someone and you know you have that
like insane chemistry and you have
you're going to have like that
mind-blowing sex to like run like hell
from that person because that means
they're like super toxic for you
well like have you ever had like insane
mind-blowing sex with someone that you
didn't have like a crazy tumultuous
relationship with or has it have you
ever had an amazing sexual experience
that turned into something good no my
last girlfriend we had we were a good
fit in bed but then the rest not so much
but then we stayed together because that
the sex was good exactly that's so funny
I've had it works like really good sex
in the beginning and then it just
overtime it's like what the [ __ ] you
know three attic really yeah and I mean
that happens a lot to me I don't know
I'll be like really into it you haven't
no like like super into it and then you
just get well I guess for guys it might
be different but I'll get sick of this
you know sure shitty to say but it's
like unless I'm really into the girl and
like which my past you know previous
girlfriends I have been but then I have
had girlfriends where I'm like all it's
[ __ ] sex is amazing it's all the time
and then toward the end I'm just like
alright oh I'd rather work off or
something really I think it is different
for well if when I've been with guys
I've only had three guys that like the
sex was so mind-blowing that I'm kind of
like I'm like kind of like an addict so
if the sex is that crazy I want it all
the time and I won't get tired of it but
usually with those guys like
everything else has been bad like that's
been and is it consistent decide yeah
like when you [ __ ] them because for me
it'll be like okay cool like I said I
was like all right doing it all the
first time yeah yeah and every [ __ ]
time you want you expect this crazy
[ __ ] thing every single time and the
dudes like it doesn't have to be like I
mean I I'm lucky because I get off
easily and like so it doesn't even have
to be all about the sex like I mean like
I'm cool if I'm cool if a guy just gets
me off like with his hand while watch a
movie like it doesn't have to be [ __ ]
all the time most guys I date cuz I like
older guys can't [ __ ] me as much as I
want because older guys I want to [ __ ]
that much like you you want to [ __ ] a
lot it sounds like I lately know um but
a year ago yeah it was like almost like
her priority but lately thankfully I've
chilled out and I can like relax a
little bit and just like hang out with
friends oh this is like [ __ ] sex
addict now I don't have to [ __ ]
everything I see if my travel-size
flashlight is take some rest
you can finally relax a little bit is
the [ __ ] best so yeah I went a little
crazy I grieved I agree I was
heartbroken and I grieved through dang
reel in my theory yeah I think I do the
same thing I think I work too much to
even think about like I don't know I
think for you it's a little bit
different but I don't [ __ ] even care
unless it's like in my lap it's a dream
right like pursue [ __ ] really anymore I
guess I'm old not all 35 I don't even
[ __ ] care I really have a [ __ ] yeah
it's kind of liberating dude I just
don't care anymore and you get more work
done and then yeah I did we're focusing
on stand-up and [ __ ] but then like it's
funny because chicks will be like what
you know they're like trying to throw it
or something you're like you don't care
and it's like a totally drives girl yeah
oh what the [ __ ] why is this guy like
whatever like what the [ __ ] or they make
some you want you more a hundred percent
yeah yeah yes I never I don't know I was
just talking to my girlfriend today
about how it's like I feel like there's
a switch lately maybe it's just la I
don't know if it's nationwide I'm
curious you guys have to let me know
that there's like a switch lately we're
like the girls have become like the guys
like the
girl already chasing the guys start
happening I mean like even with like
bumble and she like that where the
chicks like pursue and then like the
women's rights things like every
everybody wants to be equal and you know
I mean I get it's like yes the natural
progression it's like okay now women
wanted me to do like I don't feel like
we have any power and more like we used
to it used to be like the [ __ ] with the
power right now I feel like the dick is
you guys something has happened all
right it's like has the power yeah I
don't know I mean it's the same [ __ ]
it's like you hear I don't know you hear
these like women talk about I want to be
treated this way I don't know if this is
going to make any sense but it's like
you know you want it you want to be
empowered and [ __ ] but at the same time
you want the guy to pursue you that way
but then it's offensive if he does I
don't know I don't I'm very confused by
the whole thing it's like I tweeted the
other day I said if a guy tries to if a
guy just wants to bang me I get annoyed
but if a guy doesn't try to bang me I
get it yeah it's a double-edged sword
like where the [ __ ] you yeah when Alma
yeah what do you do well this is what I
mean by that is just like there's a lot
of guys that I'll go out with and I'll
think they're really into me but them
once we [ __ ] I can tell that they just
were like it was almost like a trophy
thing yeah I go [ __ ] and then it's
over that's it but then there are other
guys that I'll go out with that I'll be
really like I went out with a guy the
other night I'm like I'm into him it was
like a really good date I thought it was
a date this is where I where girls get
confused I went out with this guy
thought it was a date we had a really
good time and then we hung out for like
four hours and it was one of those
nights where like I we got the check and
I was like okay well this was really fun
I was ready to like bounce and then he
was like oh let's go to another spot
like so he's keeping it going and then
at the end of the night he just gave me
like a real like bro a hug and I was oh
you were totally thinking like oh we're
gonna [ __ ] nobody thought he'd at least
kiss me you know because we had never
kissed we'd hung out like two or three
times but it kind of been norm like a
group setting the other time but this
was the first like one alone anything I
do this is we're going to do some
thought something would happen so then
when it didn't I left and I was like to
my friends it was like
you think I should have offered to pay
because he paid but someone you didn't
try to kiss me then in my head I was
like maybe he just was hanging we were
hanging as friends if Fox where the
girls had well that it's become so
confusing for everybody you know like
that whole scenario it's like what did
did we
and I think texting has a lot to do with
it Oh what is happening and they asked
you out in a text you don't know the
tone the [ __ ] voice totally you know
right it's all that and it's like you
don't talk to them until you [ __ ] see
them at the bar or whatever right like
you don't talk to them until you walk in
you go hey and then it just then you got
a [ __ ] decode everything and [ __ ]
it's so true and then yeah nowadays like
as a guy was like do I pay every time do
I let her pay I just saw I think I just
saw a thing where this chick was my
buddy was just showing it to me was like
a chick on one of these talk shows and
she's like well I just went out with
this guy and the bill is $20 and he
wanted to split like it what if she was
it was like one of these feminists like
type of shows were there like you know
women empowerment and then she was like
and he wouldn't pay for the meal it's
like I'm old school but it's like what
the [ __ ] are you talking about like
you're either [ __ ] content you either
pay that yeah you [ __ ] do the thing
or pay half or you [ __ ] paid for the
meal and you be equal or you don't
expect that [ __ ] and then one of those
shows I'm like what the [ __ ] like these
people were so hypocritical and like
it's confused you know it's like you
want to be empowered but then you want
the [ __ ] guy to buy the meals and
drinks and everything it's like dude
what the [ __ ] are you doing Linc I admit
that when it comes to like guys I'm kind
of old-school like I want the guy to be
the guy that doesn't mean you have to
pay forever but little stuff like I want
to go in the door do this [ __ ] yeah you
can't do it it's just like a sign of
like hey you're my girl and I care about
you or you know like every girl at the
end of day no matter like and I'm like a
pretty alpha chick but at the end of the
day like the guys I'm really attracted
to our guys that make me feel like super
girly like guys that like are really
protective or you know and I said but I
think that's like just that's human
nature that's right it's like hard wired
inside of us right holy I mean like it's
yeah and then there are some people that
and I'm not saying about like wages and
[ __ ] like equality I feel like yeah
everybody should [ __ ] be and I'm
I feel like you know like they should
have equality but I'm not saying like
there's some [ __ ] you know yeah like if
you go to goes work at Burger King right
we should make the same for our person I
mean that core that's not a [ __ ]
issue
yeah that's not even a thing but at the
end of the day it's like there are
certain things guys that are guide that
guys do and certain things that girls do
that I don't know women do better and
guys do better and it's never going to
be equal yeah there's some [ __ ] guys
will do way better than girls and
there's some [ __ ] girls will do way
better than guys and it's just going to
be that way I totally and I don't I know
there's gonna be some that try to cross
over and maybe some women that do the
[ __ ] that guys do really good and
there's gonna be some [ __ ] you know but
yeah but it's not I don't think that's
the [ __ ] issue I agree
I totally there's like if I have a
girlfriend I want to take her out I want
to be the guy you know take her out and
[ __ ] fire dinner and chili I don't
think she should kill your [ __ ] nut
you know yeah like less than no I want
to try take you out and there's stuff
you can do as a girl to support a guy
that's not like I will admit that I
don't expect a guy to pay for me every
time but I have dated guys like I dated
a guy that the second time we went it
the first time we went out I kind of
reach for my wallet of course he was
like I got it
the second time we went out he just said
to me he goes listen I'm real old-school
I don't like girls pay for anything so
whenever we're together don't bother
trying to pay for anything
it'll just honestly bother me and it was
the biggest relief when he said that not
because I was like oh this guy's gonna
pay for no but it's always like
uncomfortable that moment when yo comes
and you're like [ __ ] do I offer to pay
ya and then it's like also as a chick
that makes you go oh this guy treats me
so well and then it makes you want to do
more [ __ ] for them like it makes you
want to treat like it makes you want to
like serve all their friends beers while
they're watching football like whatever
there are three women in this town in LA
that are [ __ ] just takers so that's
funny no either you're not every girl
here good point you know I'm saying so
those [ __ ] girls ruin it for you
because then the guys get jaded by that
chick that they're buying everything for
all the [ __ ] time I got on mine you
know going out and taking a girl and
doing whatever if she doesn't offer that
bothers me though like the first time
first couple times or whatever and if
it's like a mutual thing that we went
out like I'll always be paying
you know that that initial whatever word
right and then but if she doesn't even
go like oh [ __ ] you know it just makes
me feel weird though because I never
know because I will admit like the the
guy went out with the other night so the
server puts the check down he grabbed it
right away and put his card on it and
then like it always crosses my mind like
I want to offer but sometimes I know
yeah it's like sometimes and I when I
what I just said is like sometimes I'll
just take the check and pay for it too
but but there's some times where you're
I don't know what it is but it's like
when it's an appropriate situation and
it's awkward or some [ __ ] or there's
like a little gap in it or if I'm like
maybe in the bathroom or something and
the bill comes and there isn't like oh
hey you know some [ __ ] or like whatever
it is not like overly yeah like a little
bit of like hey yeah but what if you
went to the bathroom and she paid it and
you came back and was paid I'm like a
first bit on a first day that was
[ __ ] cool I wouldn't I wouldn't feel
like less than a man but I would just
take her out and do something else you
know like really I'll [ __ ] take us a
deserter I'll [ __ ] do something
you know or I would just decade oh you
don't have to do that you know and that
would be our thing but if initially and
I didn't know her and she just sat there
and was like waiting I have to turn off
for sure I'm saying I don't know what it
I don't know if I'm even explaining this
correctly but no I'm alright it's too
much it's like yeah I know what you mean
it's hard to explain though but because
there's different situations for it you
know there's like some times where it's
appropriate some times where it's not
when you expect a girl to start paying
if you're doing your like boyfriend girl
you've been dating forever and it's like
every meal can't be like [ __ ]
one-sided you know what I mean like one
for and even like some chicks like you
know they'll pay cuz the guys like
doesn't have a job or some [ __ ] or like
cotton specially you know like they'll
meet a girl and she's had kind of taken
care of him like it can't be like that
all the time
no you know I've been in situations like
that where I've been making way less
than the girl I'm dating and it's like
in the early years of comedy and it's
you pick all I got this I got this and
it would be maybe more so hurt her
paying for more of the [ __ ] but then I'd
always come through with you know
something yeah you know that's sweet I
thought girls buy me drinks like we meet
we'll meet up for drinks
and she'll like get the first round I'm
always like oh my god but that's like
able to move that chicks never do that
is just such a
like okay you're not one of those
[ __ ] taker chicks and it's like right
it's a good move I think sometimes I've
gone out with guys where they'll get the
first round of drinks and then I'll get
the second round of drinks and I'm not
going to lie I do it but in the back of
my mind as a girl if it's a first date
and the guy lets you pay for something
oh the first day is a different type of
[ __ ] yeah but I'm a different type of
thing I think or if they go like oh I'll
get that one and if I'm into the girl I
won't let her pay I don't think yeah
yeah and sometimes you know you might
the girl you're on a date with you might
know that she's like poor then I'll just
do it out of logic cuz like and I know I
got yeah that's right you're poor yeah
you're I find them simple I get
embarrassed to let guys see where I live
like I I'm I'm going out with a guy
tonight who has money and I'm and he
offered to take me to dinner and I want
to meet him there too that don't want
him to see where I live because it's so
good that I'm like this [ __ ] is
going to be like oh [ __ ] I can't date
the split what's your address
hahaha I already found you this I mean
I'm in tight al but it's very block to
block but like my blog it's so ghetto
it's so bad so it's like I never want
guys to come there ever kind of like
when girls have like shitty cars or
something I'm like alright because I
most of my life I'd had like shitty cars
my can relate to you really real person
oh that's good
but yeah yeah no cares about your cars
and all that [ __ ] that bothers me so
much it just reminds me like Newport in
Orange County and like that life total
you know I had a girl I wasn't on a date
with her but with a group of people and
I have a I Drive a Camry which is like
not impressive but I'd said like I just
got a car I got a Camry I like played it
off like it's not awesome but it's not
this girl was like ah she'll chill it's
like instant turnoff looks like I'm too
old to you know who actually cares about
that you know what I do care about if
the guy's car is clean like if I get in
your car and it's gross and there's like
french fries and [ __ ] all over the place
that's but if your car is clean it could
be like a total piece of [ __ ] and I
don't care but same with apartment if
your apartments nice but your
neighborhoods ghetto like who care as
long as your places and gross right I
have trouble cleaning out that
myself in my apartment you do if you
have a girl over I'll bet you clean it
up I do yeah yeah right now I'm super
single it looks like I'm still from
trying to move into my apartment it's
like I don't have any furniture no
furnitures like one couch ring let's
settle joke you come home with Tony
though we got robbed yeah later that
joke somebody's old yeah I mean it's
like some hack I forget but I know you
exactly yeah like man and they walk in
it's a TV show but also I remember
seeing on somebody special years ago but
he comes in and goes we got Rock wait
wait didn't mean Edwards used to do both
oh yeah yeah yeah nobody even on the
floor dancing bag yeah he did a bit
about that was he in yeah yeah yeah
that's right you take girls back and be
like oh [ __ ] no he she does it that way
I just fun you know yeah yeah but then
ei I know that - yeah so funny
well we're almost out of time I feel
like you guys gave me a lot like I
always like to end the podcast is like a
worst date story but I feel like dude
can you think of any awful just terrible
have you had any terrible dates I've had
some terrible dates I'd have to think of
like a good one I wish I would have
thought of like a good one okay I mean
maybe something like I'm trying to think
if I've had a really I kind of got stood
up the other night I think sorta I don't
know I [ __ ] this is what I'm talking
about I I said to a guy like um we were
texting back and forth a bunch and then
I was like I have a show tonight we
should hang after and he's like that
would be great let's do it and then he's
like text me from your show and then I
text him from the show and then he never
answered and so like I was embarrassing
his fault because I told all my friends
the show like oh they're all like what
are you doing after I'm like I'm going
Audrina this guy's yeah and then they
were all like where's your guy and I was
like I guess he's not coming like I felt
so dumb so but then it then I decided to
leave with my friends and go somewhere
else and then of course like two hours
later he hit me all up well not even he
was just like I'm trying to get food
where are you at and I was like trying
to I'm out with my friends now and then
it was like he was answering like every
like 20 minutes like he wasn't answer
right away so I finally was just like
[ __ ] it but then II felt real bad he was
like I didn't I didn't really know we
had like set plans I totally want to
hang again so that's what you're talking
about with like the texting
miscommunicated I actually [ __ ] it up
yeah I don't know I'd rather talk on the
phone and [ __ ] but it's like so weird
now to do you can't do it even now
though even now when you called me to go
can I park outside the pocket wait what
yeah I like that I go oh my God he's
calling on the other instead of [ __ ]
texting and sitting there waiting for
the [ __ ] response and you don't know
what they mean by the [ __ ]
yeah also it's smart to call because you
might not like someone by the end of I
gave a hot guy my number and then he
called me we talked for 15 after 15
minutes ago I [ __ ] can't even imagine
going ahead with this guy I've had the
same thing where I go dude I can't talk
to you that's there ain't no way that
I'd ever that's why I like talking to
somebody on the phone when I mean it
yeah I think it's so smart I did that
and then I actually just told the guy
honestly after we got off the phone he's
like he text me the next day like when
should we go out and I said to be honest
once we talked on the phone I wasn't
really feeling it am shallow a
[ __ ] down everyone wouldn't you
rather die it's but it's so hard to like
yeah cuz guys ego sometimes are so
[ __ ] frailing yeah he showed up at my
show the next night at the Laugh Factory
anyway and then he was like I just
thought if we hung out in person maybe
you know maybe I could convince you yeah
that's honestly what he said and I was
like I'm really always attractive yeah
yeah and he was like real high and drunk
and stuff at the show too so I was like
this is not helping yeah so I had a
couple good date sales this week I had a
date recently where the girl was very
rude to waitstaff oh that's a
deal-breaker
yeah Emma's a [ __ ] be rude to the
waitstaff done deal she like raises her
voice no no no where's my grilled cheese
nothing oh my god and shorter girl
changes right pissed you took her to a
[ __ ] grill to pray first I don't know
yeah give me my ring hang on where the
[ __ ] eating grilled baby yeah
seriously I didn't even really serve
girl cheese in a first date right come
on yeah where did you take this one oh
great spot they got the guy
they got SpaghettiOs and of course I'm
not in my defense it was the late night
nanny at a bar and had really popular
grilled cheese okay fair enough
my date was rude Wow got shit-faced and
then I was like I'm going home oh if she
lives downtown
I can't that's a different world yeah it
really is I gave my number to a guy who
I found out lives in Reseda and I was
like this is never gonna happen like
that's only by the way like for people
that don't live here it's like 15 miles
but it feels like you know light-years
away remember do a show at the Ice House
people like ah that's Edina oh yeah get
out there's like Iran's 20 minutes my
guy all right I'm here you don't have to
give one if you don't have one you're
amazing a bad date a bad day no I mean I
have tons of them I have so many of them
but [ __ ] like that like where I'm just
like [ __ ] lost interest in the date
and I'm just like an idiot and I just
don't you know yeah tons of [ __ ] like
that or where we've gotten in a fight I
mean on a date yeah hey about some [ __ ]
I go the and I just know like while
we're talking I'm like the disc is not
going to go any further at all you know
based on some sort of like disagreement
we have whether it's like I don't know
just political yeah but whatever it is
yeah her stance on some [ __ ] and I'm
like oh wow I can't even [ __ ] there's
like dogs or some [ __ ] or it's like
dying somewhere hey like dogs
no just whatever like oh you have and
just I could see a coldness to them when
I talk to you I say oh I've got a dog oh
okay well whatever I was on a date
recently the girl was amazing beautiful
laughing it a lot of my jokes a lot but
then she's like I'm super Christian I'm
a creationist which means like I think
she doesn't believe in dinosaurs oh my
god so I was just like crazy she's crazy
you like this [ __ ] doesn't believe in
dinosaurs hell no and how Hanks was take
her to get a grilled cheese oh man well
listen you guys are both awesome I love
you both so much I think you're both
amazing and tell everybody where they
can find you so everyone can follow you
I'm ride dune everywhere ride hoon ride
dune which was my aim screen name in
high school and now I'm stuck with it
really idea that's right yeah you're a I
am what about you just add a mere comedy
is everything income your comedy calm
website I love these thank you guys both
for being here they're both very
attractive and it seems both available
so make sure you guys hit them up I get
a commercial idea I don't wanna [ __ ] me
in that's really you know what's funny
is I had the BIR Zeit rip what's on here
these triplet comedian guys last week
and I swear to god one of them message
me yesterday and goes hey I just want to
tell you thanks because some chick
listen to me on your podcast and she'd
DM me and we end up hooking up oh my god
I was like yeah well that happens guys
okay no if you please love dogs and
don't be mean to the Wayne staff
no one's gonna be a meek I know I'm like
so shitty here I go I don't [ __ ] know
I'm 35 my dick doesn't work right you're
like I don't care about sex I love math
I do it out a light bulb is such a bad
like [ __ ] showing here I go [ __ ] that
this suck you're stupid
guys make sure you subscribe to the
podcast make sure you subscribe to all
the all things comedy shows make sure
you check out bio clarity calm and use
my discount code date and follow me @kq
funny see you guys next time bye bye you